of lamb with spinach and pine nuts
bath meats are perfect for special
occasions they look impressive taste
amazing but more importantly they are so
simple to do
pan on for the stuffing it's a saddle of
lamb basically a sort of Rolls-Royce cut
perfectly shaped and it suits stuffing
to an absolute tea but the stuffing
finely chop an onion
garlic
nice thin slices
oil in
onions and garlic in
[Music]
salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
beautifully seasoned so it helps to
season the inside of the lamb now we've
got the color on those onions I'm going
to throw in some pine nuts and that
helps to give a bit of a texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in and just lay the spinach over
the pine nuts it looks like a lot of
spinach that's going to condense and
disappear almost instantly
just more flavor it spinach when you
saute it as opposed to steaming it or
boiling it gas off and look at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
bread crumbs crumbled feta over the
spinach feta cheese adds a beautifully
salty sharp and creamy flavor
what this does
it brings our stuffing together
now
open up the lamb keep those little
fillets to the side that's the channel
that we want to stuff so I want to just
open that up a little bit there salt
and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in
we're going to season it with
Sumo sumac is a wonderful lemony spice
that goes brilliantly with lamb and you
can get it in most big supermarkets and
it sort of cuts through that thick Rich
sweetness of the Lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon if you're preparing this
for the day ahead then let the stuffing
cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it something's going to
squeeze out so load up the ends
take these Beauties these little fillets
and just support that stuffing and sort
of increase that beautiful tunnel and
then from there
over there
and bring that towards you and then roll
like I said some of the stuff is going
to come out
now let's tie it first off around the
side and don't worry about some flash
which is not just tie it
one in the middle
you can get butcher string from your
local butcher or at cookware shops I got
two ties
go too tight it just forces all that
stuffing out of the Lamb when it's in
the oven
nice now I want to season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but get your tray onto the
gas oil in
get it really nicely colored
none of your stuffing's coming out of
the sides really important
look at that color beautiful it does
kick start the roasting process
gas off into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly and means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices next I'm making a
simple but sophisticated accompaniment
for the lamb top and tell the Cucumber
peel it
cut the Cucumber into three and just
core
take out all that it's just sort of
watery seedium it's spoils the flavor
slice the Cucumber
cucumber in
really nice way of making a cheap and
cheerful cucumber look glamorous we're
going to dress that cucumber with a nice
fresh yogurt a couple of tablespoons
next some fresh mint
dressing Touch of salt
Touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses
that just swings it up finish that with
lemon
mix that up
lamb is rested
carefully take off the string and then
just gently pull them back
straight edge knife that's going to cut
through that crispy fat on the outside
instantly I tied it purposely so I can
get
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly look at your line
where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing
lay and down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing Meats it's for special
occasions because that is a saddle of
lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor Dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
Feast oh fresh prawn rolls one of the
keys to cooking for crowds is creating
the atmosphere and that buzz getting
your guests to sort of almost get
involved and dip in and dip out this is
an exciting fragrant wrap that is so
easy to do
first off soak the noodles these are
thin glass noodles basically bring the
kettle up to the boil and just pour just
let them steep there for a couple of
minutes the noodles are for my prawn
rolls as they soak I'm gonna make a
spicy dipping sauce to go with them
start off with sugar we're trying to
create that sweet sour salty but a
really nice sort of heated sauce as well
rice wine vinegar that will dissolve the
sugar fish sauce now that's going to
give it its saltiness next the chili I
want the seeds left in because I want
some power chili in
a little bit of garlic don't need to
chop it too finely just slice it take a
spring onion just top and tell them
slice
is bringing in nice and thinly so it's
sort of almost permeates that dipping
sauce I grew up with a love of spring
rolls but on the back of my visit to
Vietnam it sort of transform my respect
for a spring roll
give that a little mix
a little bit of coriander and fresh mint
roll them up
chop
herbs in
there's no olive oil in there
there's no cream there's no butter it's
just a really nice light dipping sauce
and wow all those senses going on
now I'm gonna make the filling for the
wraps a really nice fresh noodle salad
rinse the noodles in cold water then
chop them into bite-sized lengths
prawns peeled and cooked slice them up
the prawns give a really nice sweetness
next the vegetables I want crunch
freshness texture baby gem lettuce and
just shred that lettuce
next spring onion the good news about
these wraps is that you can make them up
in advance sit them in the fridge and
then take them out literally seconds
before you guess arrive
kill the cat
so you've got a really nice fresh
crunchy carrot
now fresh mint fresh basil and fresh
coriander together it sounds a little
bit bizarre but it tastes amazing don't
hold back with the herbs they'll really
help make the filling vibrant fresh and
aromatic finally touch a lime
squeeze that fresh lime juice over there
a couple of tablespoons of your dipping
sauce
don't put too much in there it just
makes all the filling too wet just give
that
a really good mix that's a very quick
simple salad to eat now but
let's get it into a wrap now take your
rice paper wrap literally 30 seconds in
warm water you can get rice paper wraps
from your local Asian supermarket or buy
them online
gently lift it out of the water there
beautiful lay it carefully onto your
board
[Music]
place the mixture
the bottom
don't overfill it could be a nightmare
to roll
them over first nice and tightly
halfway
then tuck in the ends
make sure
nothing's coming out the sides
useful
they're so light
fragrant
incredibly simple to do
and there you go a very delicious
fragrant
Asian wrap
certainly different to the Chinese
spring rolls I grew up with